cette campagne ne ressemblera assurément
à aucune autre parce qu'elle sera sous
la contrainte de la pandémie nous avons
néanmoins un devoir commun c'est qu'elle
soit le moment où on informera les
français et où on débattra du destin de
la france et de l'avenir de la france
la pandémie ne doit en aucun cas mettre
sous cloche
les nombreuses questions de nature
économique social culturel identitaire
que les français se posent et auquel
nous devons apporter des réponses plus
que des réponses des solutions
une échéance présidentielle ça n'est pas
qu'une question de personnes c'est
d'abord un choix de société
alors soyez en certains nous allons y
prendre activement notre part nous
allons y prendre activement notre part
autour des valeurs et des convictions
qui sont les nôtres
l'autorité la liberté la dignité mon
projet il est clair je veux rétablir
l'autorité la liberté et la dignité
l'autorité c'est à dire ramener l'ordre
dans nos frontières dans la rue comme
dans nos comptes
la liberté pour redonner de l'air à la
société et à tous les français en des
bureaucraties cre attisant en
simplifiant notre état et puis nous
reparlerons de libertés publiques
enfin la dignité la dignité pour réparer
les fractures augmenter les salaires les
retraites
permettre de gagner plus et donner sa
chance à chaque enfant de france en
refondant l'école républicaine et en
donnant à chacun un accès égal à la
santé
il s'agit d'un vrai projet de société
autorités liberté dignité qui a pour
vocation de lever un espoir de créer une
nouvelle ère et de restaurer la fierté
d'être français
en un mot il faut que
tout change pour que la france reste
elle même et c'est ce que nous croyons
ici nous croyons qu'il ya besoin d'un
niemand ce vent de changement pour que
notre pays reste au premier rang pour
que l'autre loi reste respecter pour que
la république soit consolidée et pour
que les français vivent mieux en paix
unis